today well today as ever we're going to
listen to our subscribers and a lot of
them keep saying well you haven't really
done regular expressions head on you
keep on mentioning them as though we
know all about them but we don't it will
be nice to have a sort of regular
expressions explained as it were so
although I'm gonna do my best to do
regular expressions completely as a
one-off no previous experience needed
for those of you look at it and think oh
come on this relates to something else
we will give you the link to go to the
previous episodes and you can get more
details about just how it links into
other things to those of you who think I
must be infinitely old and personal
friends of all these people well I am of
some of them but not all and today's
hero is called Steven cleany
he's the man who in the mid 1950s
invented regular expressions what claim
he wanted was a way that he didn't have
to draw diagrams like this one but that
he could abbreviate what the automaton
was doing so I'm going to number these
days 0 1 & 2 and I'm going to label this
one over here as being the finish stage
and this is going to be an incredibly
simple string fragment to fragment of a
string of characters that we're gonna
recognize this is the automaton way of
depicting it at the start or in state 0
and we're going to say that in state 0
as you are analyzing your input string
we've put some input strings down here
that this thing will be able to
recognize if what you see at the start
of your string at the moment not being
coped with is a letter a then you're
going to state 1 if let's take the
simplest one I want to recognize if in
state 1 you've code through the a if the
next character is C then that is
acceptable so I write a C over that
transition arc here and that gets me
into state to you
usually in the finish stages sometimes
distinguished by drawing a sort of
double circle like that
so you just danced it say ah that's it
so yeah what I've drawn there certainly
recognizes the string AC frankly
electronics engineers and so on we're
using these not in the late fifties in
the early 50s they use them for creating
and understanding what they called state
machines and as I say cleany sort of
like the idea like the pictorial
notation but wanted to see if he could
get it to be more compact so let's just
finish the story by saying that if you
come around on this loop and re-enter
stay warm you can do so by recognizing a
B in the string
so we've already shown that it can
recognize a C you just come here you
start you get an A you see a C and
you're finished but equally as we now
see it would also accept a b c start
here c na if the next character in your
string is a be fine you accept it but
you come back into state one although it
doesn't explicitly involve a stack this
is like a sort of iterative recursive
re-entry into the same state but the
only way out of that state to the finish
is fire accepting a C at the end of the
string for number two you can keep going
around this B loop as long as you want
it will certainly accept a b b c a three
b c and so on and effectively what
cleaner came up with as being a good way
of talking about these things over the
phone in not having to draw diagrams is
to say in his regular expression
notation that it accepts a B star C and
this is the first bit of cleaner
invented notation that star which is we
almost all of us now know means zero or
more of where we are then the strings
that that automaton accepts is a
followed by zero or more B's thing
the same and the nice thing about this
regular expression notation is just look
at how compact it is it is just so much
easier to handle in a program than
trying to do elementary computer
graphics and literally draw your self
automata although for pictorially I
think everybody like this way of
sketching out what your automaton would
accept those of you some of you may have
seen it if not follow the link out to
the things we did about three years ago
you'll find in there an automaton that
accepts 25 pence in order to issue a
parking permit it's all done with quite
complicated but locally simple little
transitions on either coins or
characters or whatever so just to
underline and re-emphasize why this
regular expression notation of cleaners
was seized upon because it was so
compact is let's complete the triangle
one side the triangle is the automaton
approach and other side the trial we've
now seen is a regular expression that
broke completely equivalent but if we
look at the Chomsky grammar approach
done on the playlist would that be
compact and nice not so much the rules
on Chomsky grammars in their purest form
is that if you use a capital letter that
is a so-called non-terminal symbol
there'll be another left hand side rule
that develops it further
whereas lowercase literally means what
it says
so this means well Chomsky tended to
call them all sentences a sentence in
this limited language is a little letter
a followed by anything that's a B can be
so I have to complete this by say well
what kind of capital B become well again
look at the automaton diagram to which
is completely equivalent what happens
with a B is you can spit out a lowercase
letter B or a B or you can have a much
simpler rule that says a capital B can
just become the letter C so then we are
instead of one small line we've got
three lines and if you're doing it the
gram
and you might say oh well can't you
abbreviate that grammar a bit more it's
it's awful having to do three lines like
that it's very verbose yeah here's the
here is the aloud shortening but it's
not much is you could say alright I will
allow myself the luxury of the aw bar
and put a C there so it's down to two
lines now not three what it's saying is
a B can be a lowercase B followed by
recursively entry into B again or it can
just be a letter C so would after two
lines but it's still nowhere near as
compact and nice as the regular
expression is and what a must absolutely
emphasized can't emphasize too much and
should put double headed arrows all over
the place here
is that all of these things the
automaton diagram the regular expression
the grammar they are all completely
equivalent to each other those have you
been through mathematics courses will
know your instructors go on and on and
on about no I'm not asking you whether
one is a subset of the other or one is
contained within the other but there's a
little bit extra no they are completely
and totally equivalent there is not a
single thing that one will accept that
the other won't and vice versa so it's
just a matter of convenience of the
notation
perhaps if you're computer scientists
for using in a programming context and I
think the other thing that also had to
be coped with is to say well alright you
can do it as a Thomason diagram you can
do it as a regular expression it is a
grammar regular expressions looking good
because of the compactness of the
notation but are we sure that there
aren't any eggs in this process of
saying they're equal
well one snag that did occur and was
recognized very early on in the late
nineteen fifties and all of this is that
sometimes looking at it
let's forget it for me or Thomas and
diagram the point of view sometimes you
get a situation where what you want is
what's called non-deterministic in other
words I'm happy here because there's
only one exit from zero to get you into
one it's labeled a how would it be if I
took another arrow out of zero and said
a could also lead you somewhere else so
let's just draw up a little diagram of
what horrors that might be what happens
and what would you do about it if you
say well my regular expression let's
call it e is actually either a B a B or
I want to recognize a B a B now how does
he useless however you know how does
that fit into anything it does
illustrate though a very very important
point which is that if you are trying to
build an automaton or recognizer for
this you've got two alternatives here
you are a state zero and you want to go
into possibly two completely different
directions but they both begin a how do
you choose for the moment I'm saying no
cheating no you're not allowed to look
ahead you just get given an a what do
you do and worse still of course it
doesn't end there
it then goes on that whichever route you
go you'll find that the next thing is
you've got to recognize a B so the
common factor if you like and it's just
like factorizing expressions in algebra
you know X cube minus 1 take out an x
squared factor out out at the front its
x squared X minus 1 that's what it's
similar in principle to that now of
course they do
change a bit eventually because this one
accepts an area here and then finishes
up by
accepting a B this one next one goes a B
and another B and finally it gets down
into the finished State as well okay
well it looks trivial but what are you
gonna do
here you are the programmer trying to
implement this you look at the string
and he said there's two ways I can cope
with this the most amazing thing about
this is that to theoreticians in the
late 50s won the Turing ACM award for
saying it will always be possible to
turn the non-deterministic one into a
deterministic one now how would we do
that on this case easy you start off
with zero you say that first of all
we'll accept you always do an A and then
a B that's the common factor if you like
for the start but you put your split
point here that that continues with an A
and that line continues with the B to
get the two avenues that you see other
so we factorizing out the a and the B
and the story was well it's alright for
us humans who are really intelligent to
see that you could do that but will it
always be possible for these things to
turn the non-deterministic one into a
deterministic one where you force it
through factorization first and the
answer from Dana Scott and Michael rub
in in the late 1950s it is always doable
so long as you stick to simple finite
state automata don't stop monkeying
around with extra RAM or stacks just
stick to them as they are you can always
do it but it can get very very hairy so
who was the first person who plunged
headlong into this and said I'm gonna do
it
answer Ken Thompson our hero from UNIX
Bell Labs in the whole lot by the late
sixties he effectively was saying this
regular expression stuff is great for
pattern matching in editors I want to
use it
but this problem of non-determinism how
do I cope with it and it is the most
amazingly farsighted piece of work you
understand when you look at this why can
Tom sneeze a legend it basically said
I'm going I know it's not deterministic
but I look at all possibilities and I'll
start pre compiling little bits of
assembler code to cope with whichever
one turns up on the day as it were and
everybody's open-mouthed about this he
also realized he said look yeah if you
don't mind doing pre-processing you can
actually you know Michael and Dana have
shown us that it is possible yeah I know
how to do that but on the other hand
that could take some time because it's
all very well doing a little toy example
like this but non-determinism in a big
real-life automaton could be held a
disentangle well let me give you one
example which sounds utterly innocuous
but which I can give you so on a
complete page that you can show to the
fans about this Brian Kernighan wanted
to get a regular expression recognizer
for all of the key words and all of the
constructs in his pic language which
after all is a preprocessor for the UNIX
tear-off typesetting language he just
wanted to draw simple line diagrams so
we've got primitives like circle line
ellipse from 2 with dotted to show you
the nature line all this kind of stuff
it looks innocuous biggish but in oculus
and he put it through one of these NFA
to DFA let's stop it being
non-deterministic we want fast
recognition we want to build an engine
don't care it has more States than the
non-deterministic one but boys got to go
off like a Lamborghini right so be
prepared to spend some pre-processing
time you can put out his release a note
with pick which says the Lexx phase
takes an eon 15 minutes on a VAX 750
full stop be patient brian is always
noted for his earnest Hemmingway test
you know so that is what can come to
horn you is that be convoluting tracing
round everything to get it deterministic
it is worthwhile if you are going to be
putting huge pig scrapes through this so
we are hammering it over and over and
over again anything I've got to get this
really efficient otherwise we'll be here
forever
while we're using it on the other hand
Ken's usage of it in the UNIX editor EDD
took the pragmatic view this thing
edie in the early days because stream
editor Lee McMahon hadn't been invented
yet
just edy you can get away with very
simple regular expressions because
that's all that humans will use if
you're feeding it stuff that's been
prepared by another program that's when
your pet schemes tend to die the death
because stuff prepared by another
program can exploit little wrinkles that
cause you great difficulty but cancer no
in edy I think I can get away with
keeping it non-deterministic but
preparing and look ahead is from the
first examples of just-in-time
compilation
he took the attitude I'll look at which
way the cookie crumbles try and work out
which is the most likely and pre-compute
pieces are fast assembler code that I
can put in to actually execute these
things and it was the most amazing
flexible system it basically adapts it
to the input it is a good example of
just-in-time compilation
what Kansas's I'll do it as I need it
Brian in pick couldn't say that because
it's basically much more like a compiler
and it's a compiler that's been driven
by reams of externally provided input so
two approaches to the same thing are you
going to make it deterministic in all
cases ahead of time are you gonna cope
with it as you go the man goes to town
as we would say to town the man goes
sounded to me 20 years going I first
stumbled on this very much like Yoda the
Jedi
for those of you coming into this cold
and direct because you saw the word
Yoder and grep over the entire universe